[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend Ihnen zwei Reisen heute die
zugleich einem ganzes Bündel von
immensen Herausforderungen führen der
Bundeskanzler ist in Rumänien sein
Vizekanzler in der Ukraine wir beginnen
in Kiew wo Robert Habeck als einer der
letzten aus dem Bundeskabinett seit
Ausbruch des Krieges gegen die Ukraine
begrüßt wurde nachdem er vor dem Krieg
mal einer der ersten war der dort
Defensive Waffen für das Land gefordert
hatte und sich damit viel Ärger auch und
gerade bei seinen grünen einhandelte
eine Delegation der deutschen Wirtschaft
hat der Wirtschaftsminister mit im
Sonderzug denn eins ist klar in der
Ukraine wartet jenseits von Militär und
Waffen eine zivile Mammutaufgabe Anne
Brühl berichtet
vorbei an Sandsäcken und einem
zerstörten Transformator so fängt für
Robert Habeck der Tag in der Ukraine an
Besuch in einem Umspannwerk das schon
dreimal von russischen Raketen und
Drohnen getroffen wurde
ein Mann wurde verletzt alle Mitarbeiter
wurden evakuiert fünf Minuten vorher
aber einer hat es nicht schnell genug
raus geschafft
die kritische Infrastruktur ist immer
noch Hauptziel der russischen Angriffe
und doch läuft alles normal die Schäden
werden innerhalb von Stunden behoben
auch mit Krediten aus Deutschland 150
Millionen Euro
die Transformatoren sind dort sie sind
viel größer als die hier sie versorgen
jeweils 150.000 Menschen mit Strom
hatten die Russen zu Beginn des Kriegs
besetzt
370 Menschen eingesperrt im Schulkeller
11 sterben die Leichen dürfen sie
tagelang nicht begraben
es ist sehr wichtig dass wir Partner
haben und dass sie das alles sehen
wichtig das zu sehen in solchen Kellern
zu sein um zu verstehen ob man der
Ukraine helfen muss
Deutschland hilft auch mit Waffen seit
einer Woche mit 18 Leopard 2 Panzern die
Sehnsucht nach Frieden muss eine
Sehnsucht nach einer Friedensordnung
sein also es darf nicht verwechselt
werden mit einer Unterwerfung unter
einem tyrannischen Angriffskrieg wenn
deutsche Waffen deutsche
Wiederaufbauhilfe für Harbeck geht es um
beides auch auf der Brücke die Scharnier
mit der Hauptstadt Kiew verbunden hat
und die von russischen Bomben zerstört
wurde die Reparatur kostet eine Million
Euro finanziert auch aus deutschen
Krediten
sie sehen dass wir ein großes Volumen an
Renovierungsbedarf haben das heißt dass
wir natürlich deutsche Unterstützung
brauchen aber nicht nur deutsche
mehr als 14 Milliarden Euro
Unterstützung hat Deutschland für die
Ukraine bereitgestellt um Kriegsschäden
zu beheben und zur Verteidigung dass
dieser Krieg noch lange nicht zu Ende
ist daran wird Habeck in der Ukraine auf
Schritt und Tritt erinnert
Robert Habeck der Vizekanzler ist jetzt
aus Kiew bei uns in der Sendung guten
Abend
sie haben gesagt sie wollten erst wieder
in die Ukraine fahren wenn sie etwas
mitbringen können Hoffnung machen auf
Wiederaufbau nach dem Krieg wie viel
Hoffnung können Sie denn da jetzt heute
machen
also vor allem gibt es eine große
Entschlossenheit in dem Land das große
Wort über das hier alle reden ist early
Recovery also Wiederaufbau anfangen
obwohl der Krieg noch andauert und
natürlich die Gefahr von
Raketenangriffen nicht vollständig
gebannt ist obwohl sie deutlich
zurückgegangen sind auch wegen der
militärischen Technik die wir
bereitgestellt haben und ich glaube
deswegen passt das ganz gut ich bin ja
mit einer Wirtschaftsdelegation hier die
erste deutsche wahrscheinlich die erste
überhaupt und das wird interessiert
aufgenommen ja mehr die Minister freuen
sich jetzt potenzielle Investoren zu
treffen welche konkreten Investitions
Entscheidungen gibt es denn bereits
also zwei sind im Vorfeld quasi
getroffen worden einmal ist glaube ich
darf ich sagen Bayer der deutsche Pharma
und Chemiekonzern wird hier 60 Millionen
investieren und dann ein Unternehmen das
hier schon in der Ukraine ansässig war
Fixit heißen die die machen hier
Baustoffe werden ihre Kapazitäten
erweitern quasi verdoppeln das wird auch
dringend gebraucht denn wenn man sich
anschaut was ist jetzt das erste was
gemacht werden muss ist halt die
Reparatur von Gebäuden und Straßen und
Brücken und wichtig daran ist dass wir
ein Instrument einsetzen dass wir
normalerweise nicht für Krieg für
Kriegsgebiete vorhalten nämlich eine
investitionsgarantie aussprechen und das
gilt auch für andere Unternehmen sollte
dieses Fabrikgebäude zerstört werden
durch Raketenangriffe beispielsweise
garantiert oder haftet der deutsche
Staat das machen wir natürlich
normalerweise nicht das viel zu
gefährlich aber in diesem Fall machen
wir das und deswegen investiert fixiert
ebenfalls jetzt sind ja die Summen für
den Wiederaufbau der Ukraine wirklich
gigantisch man weiß sie auch gar nicht
so richtig offensichtlich 411 Milliarden
Dollar kostet der Wiederaufbau sagt die
Weltbank der ukrainische
Ministerpräsident schätzt 750 Milliarden
man findet auch Schätzungen über eine
Billion haben sie überhaupt den
Überblick und wer soll das Zahlen es ist
jedenfalls mehr Geld als der als
staatliche Stellen oder die
Bundesrepublik EU und USA zusammen
aufbringen können wir werden natürlich
ein Teil auch öffentlich bezahlen müssen
mit öffentlichen Geldern aber am Ende
brauchen wir den Dreiklang aus die
Ukraine muss gute
Investitionsbedingungen schaffen es muss
Garantien Anreize bzw Sicherungen von
öffentlicher Hand geben und dann muss
das private Kapital in die Ukraine
wollen und das ist quasi der Hintergrund
meiner meines Besuchs das das private
Kapital die Unternehmen die Banken
verstehen wie sind die
Investitionsbedingungen und dann
möglichst auch den Schritt gehen und
sagen okay das ist ein interessanter
Standort wir haben ja beispielsweise in
Russland viel investiert der Markt ist
verloren jetzt könnten wir andere Märkte
suchen warum nicht die Ukraine jetzt
haben sie Harbeck heute auch sowas
gesagt wie eine Energiewende die ist in
der in der Ukraine geben müssen sie
merken ja gerade selber wie mühsam das
Projekt in Deutschland ist was macht sie
denn so sicher dass das ausgerechnet in
einer Ukraine im Krieg funktionieren
könnte wo aktuell über 90% der Energie
aus Kohle Gas und Atomanlagen kommt
ja das ist genau das Problem für die
Ukraine ich habe heute mit dem CEO also
mit dem Chef des ukrainischen Staats
Energiekonzerns gesprochen und der hat
gesagt die Kohle haben wir weitgehend
verloren das ist ja die Region im dombas
und Mario Pohl rum wo die Kohle
geschöpft wurde die Atomkraft ist
teilweise unsicher auch weil sie
beschossen wird und Gas fördert die
Ukraine teilweise selbst aber viel
abhängig die Abhängigkeit aus Russland
ist natürlich auch hier ein Thema also
müssen uns was anderes überlegen und das
andere überlegen heißt dezentrale
Systeme aufbauen und die zentrale
Systeme übersetzen die hier selber mit
Biomasse das Land ist ja ein sehr sehr
starkes Agrarland die
Materialien die übrig sind zu verwenden
und dann in große Kraftanlagen in große
Heizanlagen in große elektrische Anlagen
zu stecken eine Möglichkeit ein sehr
sonnenreiches Land das war schon vor dem
Krieg ein Thema ist dann so ein bisschen
zurückgetreten und im Winter haben die
auch aber der entscheidende ist so
ähnlich wie in Deutschland eigentlich
dass die dezentrale Aufteilung von
Energiesystemen auch eine
Versorgungssicherheit gewährleisten kann
weil sie schwerer anzugreifen sind so
und da kommt eben beides zusammen die
dekarbonisierung und die die
Dezentralisierung und sicher sein kann
man natürlich gar nicht aber ich
referiere nur was mir der Chef bis
Energieversorgungsunternehmens heute
erzählt hat sie war eine Habeck im Mai
2021 als grünen Chef in der Ukraine
damals haben sie sich ausgesprochen für
die Lieferung von defensiv Waffen und
dafür viel Gegenwind bekommen auch in
der eigenen Partei auch von Frau
Zimmermann von der FDP z.B auch von der
großen Koalition damals sie sind dann
sehr sehr schnell eingeknickt hätten sie
aus heutiger Sicht und von dem was sie
heute erleben in Kiew viel stärker auf
ihrer Position bestehen müssen
ja es ist nun Vergangenheit für
Bewältigung ich würde für mich sagen
stärker konnte man darauf gar nicht
bestehen denn
niemand anderes hat ja das als gute oder
richtige Überlegung dargestellt sondern
von überall her gab es Kritik die heute
ehrlicherweise wie hohen klingt und klar
Deutschland muss insgesamt ich glaube
alle müssen das eingestehen
dass wir diese Debatte falsch geführt
haben das ist richtig gewesen wäre die
Ukraine schon früher militärisch zu
unterstützen und das auch die
Entscheidung nach dem Kriegsbeginn
sehr spät getroffen wurden teilweise
aber nun ist sie getroffen worden und
deswegen ist es mir persönlich egal wer
damals waren was gesagt hat sondern die
entscheidende Frage ist wie schnell
kommen die versprochenen Panzer und die
nicht versprochene Munition in die
Ukraine denn das dürfen wir nicht
vergessen ich habe heute noch mal ganz
schauerliche Geschichten und Bilder
gesehen dass hier Menschen sterben
wahrscheinlich während wir reden sterben
und dass die Sehnsucht nach Frieden die
wir alle in uns haben eine Sehnsucht
nach der Friedensordnung sein muss also
nicht einer Kapitulation zu
putinsbedingungen sondern der
Wiederherstellung einer Ordnung die den
Frieden implementiert in den
völkerrechtlichen Systemen die wir
aufgebaut haben Weg der viel zu Kanzler
in Kiel vielen Dank für das Gespräch
danke Ihnen
und das Gespräch haben wir aus Termin
Gründen vor der Sendung aufgezeichnet
zwei direkte Nachbarn der Ukraine haben
heute auch Besuch bekommen aus Berlin in
Rumänien war der Bundeskanzler
persönlich und Moldau stand zumindest
ganz oben auf seiner Agenda bei den
Gesprächen in Bukarest Rumänien ist EU
und NATO Mitglied die kleine Republik
Moldau möchte dringend in die EU und
erwartet Militärhilfe die bisher eher
stiefmütterlich behandelte Region hat
plötzlich eine Schlüsselrolle Wolf
Christian Ulrich
stundenlang stehen sie an auf dem Weg
nach Westen Papiere Zoll und nach
illegal Einreisenden suchen könnte
Rumänien dem Schengen-Raum beitreten
fielen diese Kontrollen weg
ich warte hier schon seit drei Stunden
sagt Marian das ist doch Wahnsinn jeden
Tag derselbe Ärger
wir sind in Oradea das Tor nach
Siebenbürgen die Stadt hat in den
vergangenen Jahren erfolgreich
Investoren angelockt vor allem aus
Deutschland z.B das Unternehmen Papst
das Elektromotoren herstellt
Werksleiterin Dalia Unruhe meint ein
Schengen Beitritt spare dem Unternehmen
viel Geld
wir hätten dann mehr Ressourcen für
Produktion und Innovation
schon große Hoffnungen heute deshalb auf
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz in Bukarest
ich unterstütze sehr den Schengen
Beitritt Rumäniens und ich hoffe auch
dass uns das in diesem Jahr gelingt doch
schnell wird klar Schengen spielt bei
diesem Besuch nur die Nebenrolle das
bestimmende Thema ist mehr Unterstützung
für die Südostflanke der NATO lange ging
es darum der Ukraine Waffen zu liefern
jetzt geht es darum sie zu reparieren
und das soll jetzt auch in Rumänien
passieren rein Metall eröffnet demnächst
den satumare nahe der Grenze zu Ukraine
eine wartungsanlage für Panzer und
Panzerhaubitzen und angesichts jüngster
Konflikte sogar zwischen USA und
Russland über den Schwarzen Meer fordert
Rumänien noch mehr NATO Präsenz
sie unterstützen die verstärkte Präsenz
der NATO im Schwarzen Meer zu Rumäniens
Präsident Johannes das sei für den Euro
atlantischen Raum von strategischer
Bedeutung
am Nachmittag treffen Scholz und
Johannes die Präsidentin von Moldau
Meyer Sando sie steht zu Hause in Norden
unter Druck
ständig pro Putin Demos offenbar zum
Teil bezahlt vom Kremmel die russische
Propaganda stark Wirtschaft und
Energienetz noch abhängig von Putins
macht
die EU hilft Moldau deshalb mit rund
einer Milliarde Euro hilft auch dabei
neudors Energienetz so schnelles geht an
Rumänien anzuschließen alles und das
Land unabhängiger von Russland zu machen
an ihrer Seite sie sind nicht allein
du fordert heute mehr militärische Hilfe
wir versuchen unsere
verteidigungskapazitäten zu stärken und
ja dabei brauchen wir Hilfe
Deutschland bereite Hilfe vor sagt
Scholz Schengen Rüstung Investitionen
die Bundesregierung hat begriffen die
strategische Bedeutung Südosteuropas
wächst in Zeiten russischer Bedrohung
und Expansion
Sohn auf all das was heute auch noch
wichtig ist guckst du jetzt Hannah ja
gut drei Wochen haben die Berliner CDU
und die SPD verhandelt heute stellten
sie ihr gemeinsames Regierungsprogramm
für die Hauptstadt vor Schwerpunkt darin
ist unter anderem der Klimaschutz für
den mindestens fünf Milliarden Euro
vorgesehen sind zudem soll die
Verwaltung reformiert und mehr in
bezahlbare Wohnungen investiert werden
die Basis von SPD und CDU müssen dem
Vertrag noch zustimmen bei einem Jahr
von beiden Seiten könnte CDU landeschef-
Finnland steht nach der Parlamentswahl
gestern vor einem Regierungswechsel die
Sozialdemokraten der noch amtierenden
Ministerpräsidentin marien wurden mit
19,9% nur drittstärkste Kraft an erster
Stelle liegt mit 20,8 Prozent der
Stimmen die konservative Nationale
Sammlungspartei dicht gefolgt von der
rechtspopulistischen Partei die finden
und noch eine Meldung die Finnland
betrifft denn morgen soll das Land
offiziell der NATO beitreten das
erklärte Generalsekretär Stoltenberg man
werde Finnland am Rande des
Außenminister Treffens in Brüssel als 31
des Mitglied des Verteidigungsbündnisses
willkommen heißen
heute ist der offizielle Verkauf des
deutschland-tickets gestartet ab dem
ersten mai ist es dann bundesweit im nah
und Regionalverkehr für je einen Monat
gültig das Ticket gibt es abrufbar auf
dem Handy oder als Chipkarte und
übergangsweise bis Ende des Jahres auch
auf Papier soll den Umstieg auf
öffentliche Verkehrsmittel fördern und
in den meisten Bundesländern 49 Euro
kosten
vor dem Sondertribunal in Den Haag zu
kriegsverbrechendem Kosovo Krieg vor 25
Jahren hat Ex-Präsident hasheed
seine unschuldbeteuert die Anklage wirft
ihm Kriegsverbrechen und Verbrechen
gegen die Menschlichkeit vor tadschi
soll als Rebellenführer im Krieg gegen
Serbien mitverantwortlich für Folter und
Tötung von Kollaborateuren und
mutmaßlichen Verrätern gewesen sein
seine Anhänger demonstrierten vor dem
Gerichtsgebäude sie sehen in ihm einen
Kriegshelden der das Kosovo in die
Unabhängigkeit führte
es klingt wie aus einem Agatha Christie
Roman es gibt einen Mord und es gibt
viele die ein Motiv haben könnten der
Fall steht gerade zu exemplarisch für
die Situation aktuell in Russland der
Tote ist einer der aus dem ukrainischen
dornbas stammt der in Haft saß wegen
eines Banküberfalls der sich pro
russischen Rebellen anschloss und später
als Blogger bekannt wurde eine halbe
Million Menschen folgen ihm auf telegram
lesen seine Hetz und Hasstiraden über
die Ukraine und auch seine Kritik an der
russischen Militärführung die er zu
lasch findet
Wladimir Putins Krieg hat ihn zu einem
Star gemacht in Russland zu einem Star
mit vielen Feinden bloodland tatarski
ist gestern bei einer Explosion in St
Petersburg ums Leben gekommen mehr als
30 weitere Menschen wurden verletzt aber
geil
hatte viele Feinde er war
ultra-nationalistisch kritisierte immer
wieder die russische Regierung forderte
in seine militärblock eine härtere
Gangart im Krieg gegen die Ukraine wir
werden alle besiegen wir werden alle
töten wir werden alle ausrauben
in Sankt Petersburg trauern sie heute um
einen Mann der zum Töten aufrief und
schließlich selbst getötet wurde Fans
von tatarski am Ort des Anschlags
das ist schrecklich Terrorismus das
sollte nicht vergeben werden
in St Petersburg gibt es viel von diesem
Liberalen Abschaum der immer wieder
Kundgebungen gegen unseren Präsidenten
organisiert
Social Media Aufnahmen zeigen was
passiert sein soll eine junge Frau
betritt das Café hat offenbar eine
goldene Büste mitgebracht als Geschenk
für tatarski wenig später die Explosion
tatarski stirbt viele weitere werden
verletzt
aus dem Grimmel heißt es heute es gibt
Informationen das ukrainische
Spezialeinheiten in die Planung dieses
Terroranschlags verwickelt sein könnten
natürlich ist dies ein Terroranschlag
die junge Frau angeblich mit
Verbindungen zur russischen Opposition
wird am Vormittag festgenommen Teile des
Verhörs werden veröffentlicht sie gibt
zu die Büste überbracht zu haben
weiteren Fragen weicht sie aus
Oppositionspolitiker Schlossberg
vermutet sie wurde benutzt
scheint dass die Organisatoren dieses
Verbrechens beschlossen haben einen
ziemlich zynischen Weg einzuschlagen bei
dem die direkte Täterin nicht versteht
welche Aufgabe ihr übertragen wurde
die Frage ist dann wer die Fäden gezogen
hat
die Ukraine russische Terroristen der
Kreml selbst es scheint als wolle am Tag
danach jeder den Anschlag für seine
Zwecke instrumentalisieren der Chef der
Söldnergruppe Wagner widerspricht auf
telegram der Darstellung des kremme
ich würde das chiavaregime nicht für
diese Aktionen verantwortlich machen ich
denke dass es eine Gruppe von radikalen
war die kaum mit der Regierung verbunden
ist
pregorian gehört wie tartarski zu denen
die das Vorgehen in der Ukraine nicht
hart genug finden die Putin dafür immer
wieder öffentlich kritisieren
radikalen Nationalisten
zusammengearbeitet hat den viel Raum
gegeben aber jetzt verlangen die eben
mehr noch brutaleres Vorgehen noch
stärkeres Vorgehen des Militärs mehr
Aufrüstung und das ist für ihn mit Blick
auf die Misserfolge der militärischen
Kampagne in der Ukraine und die ohnehin
schon spannungsgeladene Situation in
Russland ein großes Problem trotzdem
ehrt Putin noch am Abend tatarski mit
einem Orden macht seinen einstigen
Gegner zum Helden wohl in der Hoffnung
die Kritik von rechts zumindest
zeitweise zu begraben
so jetzt noch mal du Hannah mit einer
Meldung aus der Wirtschaft bei der man
durchaus aufhorcht heute ja denn wir
blicken auf die Aufarbeitung eines der
größten Fälle von
Wirtschaftskriminalität in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik es geht um
den wirecard-skandal konkret um die
Rolle der
Wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaft Ei Frank
Bethmann wegen Pflichtverletzungen hat
nun die Aufsichtsbehörde apas eine
Strafe gegen die Wifi verhängt und ja
das in sich ja es ist das umfassendste
Paket an Strafen dass die Behörde bis
dato ausgesprochen hat auch europaweit
gibt es nichts Vergleichbares überall
Deutschland darf sich zwei Jahre lang
nicht dann Ausschreibungen für
Abschlussprüfungen bei Unternehmen von
öffentlichen Interesse beteiligen und da
sprechen wir von allen börsennotierten
Unternehmen darüber hinaus aber auch von
großen Banken und Versicherungen von all
diesen neuen Mandaten muss überall
Deutschland zwei Jahre die Finger lassen
darüber hinaus wurden saftige Geldbußen
gegen das Unternehmen und gegen einige
Mitarbeiter ausgesprochen doch abgesehen
von all diesen Strafen ist die
Entscheidung wenn dann rechtskräftig
werden sollte verheerend für den Ruf und
nicht zuletzt davon lebt eine
Wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaft was wird
ewai denn ganz konkret vorgeworfen
schwerwiegende Verstöße gegen die für
die
wirtschaftsprüfungsbranche geltenden
beruflichen Pflichten oder einfacher
gesagt viel zu nachlässig kontrollierte
Bilanzen überall war war mehr als ein
Jahrzehnt lang Abschlussprüfer von
Wirecard und hatte die Bilanzen bis 2018
uneingeschränktesiert erst 2019
verweigerte e-right das Testat das nun
abgeschlossene Verfahren sollte
aufklären welche Versäumnisse den
Wirtschaftsprüfern vorzuwerfen sind es
gilt als einmal in Stein von mehreren
bei der Aufarbeitung des
wirecard-skandals die große Frage ist
nun wie inwieweit haben die heute
festgestellt und Pflichtverletzungen
Einfluss auf mögliche
Schadenersatzklagen von Anlegern Banken
oder dem Insolvenzverwalter von Wirecard
vielen Dank Frank für diese Einordnung
die Staaten der OPEC plus haben
überraschend angekündigt ihre
Ölfördermenge zu kürzen am Mai soll die
globale Produktion demzufolge um 1,6%
gedrosselt werden was den Ölpreis in die
Höhe schnellen ließ dies könnte laut
ADAC auch Folgen an den Zap sein haben
insgesamt wird befürchtet dass der
Schritt sich auf die Inflation und damit
auch auf die Geldpolitik auswirkt
der abstiegsbedrohte Bundesligist VfB
Stuttgart bekommt einen neuen Trainer
der Verein hat Sebastian Hoeneß
verpflichtet der auf Bruno Labbadia
folgt diesem war es nicht gelungen den
VfB auf die Erfolgsspur zurückzuführen
in den vergangenen neun Spielen hatte
der Verein sieben Mal verloren
Paris will den Verlauf von E-Scootern
künftig verbieten dafür haben sich in
einer Bürgerbefragung knapp 90 Prozent
der Abstimmenden ausgesprochen die
Wahlbeteiligung lag allerdings bei
weniger als 8%. unabhängig davon
betrachte Paris den Ausgang als binden
sagte die Bürgermeisterin rund 15.000
Roller sollen die Vermieter Anfang
September aus dem Verkehr nehmen
das Handy wird heute 50 Jahre alt ein
Gerät das aus unserem Leben mittlerweile
nicht mehr wegzudenken ist doch am
dritten april 1973 war das noch anders
damals machte sein Erfinder Martin
Cooper den ersten Anruf mit einem
Mobiltelefon das allerdings alles andere
als handlich war groß wie ein
Ziegelstein mehr als ein Kilo schwer und
die Akkulaufzeit betrug gerade mal 30
Minuten erst nach und nach wurden die
Geräte immer kleiner und
massentauglicher
30 Minuten
so jetzt geht es ins Kino und in eine
ganz eigene Welt rund um Intrigen
Politik und Religion die Kairo
Verschwörung ist voller Verweise auf die
aktuelle Situation in Ägypten sie spielt
an einer Universität aus dem 10
jahrhundert und im straßengewehr einer
mega Metropole von der niemand weiß wie
viele Menschen dort eigentlich leben 17
Millionen 21 Millionen noch mehr der
Regisseur und Drehbuchautor darf seit
seinem letzten Film nicht mehr in
Ägypten einreisen er hat selbst seine
Erfahrungen gemacht mit der
Geheimpolizei dort den neuen Thriller
hat er deshalb in der Türkei gedreht und
dennoch war er ganz nah dran wie Nadja
nasser zeigt
einfach Fischers ist es die Erfüllung
eines Lebenstraums er darf an der
bedeutenden al-azar-universität in Kairo
studieren bis nächsten Tag hier gerade
angekommen na dann aber kurz nach seiner
Ankunft stirbt der großimam der
Universität der wichtigste religiöse
Führer des Landes es beginnt ein
politischer Machtkampf um seine
Nachfolge in die sich auch Militär und
Geheimdienst einmischen die Wahl des
großen
Linie eine Frage der nationalen
Sicherheit denn das geistliche Oberhaupt
der assar-universität hat großen
Einfluss auf die Gesellschaft der
Geheimdienst soll nun sicherstellen dass
nicht etwa ein regierungskritischer Imam
an die Macht kommt
der Präsident wünscht
seine Ansichten decken sich mit denen
des Präsidenten sorgen Sie dafür dass er
gewählt wird
Geheimdienst Offizier Ibrahim sucht sich
dafür einen Spitzel an der Universität
die Wahl fällt auf den schüchternen Adam
der junge Student wird zum Spielball der
Mächte
nach Sonnenuntergang gehst du durch das
Tor dass der sie so gezeigt hat und
gerät in einen tödlichen Strudel aus
Intrigen Korruption und Gewalt
[Musik]
Adam verkörpert für mich den
herzzerreißendsten Aspekt von Diktaturen
wenn du ein Talent hast wenn du
intelligent bist dann wirst du vom Staat
benutzt und missbraucht werden
sie geben dir zwei Möglichkeiten sie
sagen entweder wir zerstören dich oder
du arbeitest für uns aber beide
Möglichkeiten bedeuten das gleiche denn
beide werden dich zerstören
Adam gerät zwischen die Fronten für wen
arbeitest du
jetzt pass mal auf
was meinst du wie weit ist es bis da
unten es ist ein gefährliches Spiel in
dem es nur Verlierer gibt
12 Meter
würde ich schätzen der Film ist ein
spannender Thriller ein Blick in eine
Welt von der sonst wenig nach außen
dringt und es ist ein hochpolitischer
Film offen prangert er Missstände und
Korruption in Ägypten an gedreht wurde
er deshalb hauptsächlich in Istanbul
nicht in
kairoy die Armee hat jeden Aspekt
ägyptischen Lebens unter Kontrolle es
gibt dort überhaupt keine Freiheit Leute
haben mich gefragt überschreitest du mit
dem Film nicht eine rote Linie aber in
Ägypten überschreitest du schon eine
rote Linie wenn du sagst diese Straße
ist kaputt und müsste man repariert
werden allein dafür kannst du nachts
abgeholt werden weil das unpatriotisch
ist und leider ist das nicht nur in
Ägypten so sondern in den meisten Teilen
der Welt
die Kairo Verschwörung ist ein düsterer
Krimi über den Missbrauch von Macht und
Religion faszinierend und sehr aktuell
ein Film über Ägypten den niemand in
Ägypten hätte machen können wie der
Regisseur sagt ab Donnerstag bei uns
hier im Kino und damit sagen wir zwei
stellvertreten für das gesamte heute
schon mal Team danke fürs Interesse und
unser heute journal up gibt es gegen
0:30 Uhr mit Nazan göktdemir Ihnen
[Musik]
guten Abend hoch Meryem liegt über
Dänemark und wird umzingelt von gleich
mehreren Teams das eine tief hier bei
Island das kommt uns langsam von West
näher interessanter aber noch ist dieses
kleine tief das morgen einige Wolken in
den Osten schickt ja heute Nacht ist es
meist klar Seiten gibt es ein paar
Schneeschauer und das ganze bei einem
Wind aus nordöstlichen Richtung so wird
es kalt die Temperaturen sinken auf null
Grad in Ostfriesland und bis minus 7
Grad am alten Rand wenn sie empfindliche
Pflanzen draußen haben dann sollten Sie
sie besser schützen auch morgen bleibt
es kalt in den östlichen Mittelgebirge
und auch im Berchtesgadener Land mit nur
so zwei bis vier Grad sonst werden 5 bis
8 Grad erreichen da rein reicht es für
zwei stellige Zähne oder 11 Grad morgen
wird es zwischen dem Allgäu und dem
oberrainern freundlichsten sonst gibt's
einige Wolkenfelder besonders im Osten
da könnte es dann am Nachmittag mal für
ein bisschen Regen oder ein bisschen
Schnee reichen bei nordostend an Wetter
wird sich am Mittwoch noch wenig ändern
am Donnerstag wird es dann im Nordwesten
deutlich wechselhafter und zum
Karfreitag auch milder mit 7 bis 14 Grad
vielleicht interessiert Sie ja wie das
zu Ostern aussieht eine große Umstellung
der Wetterlage ist für es nicht in Sicht
deutlich milder als bei uns in Mittel-
und Westeuropa wird es über Ostern wohl
im Süden der iberischen Halbinsel sein
oder auch Zypern bei 25 Grad das ist
noch ein bisschen Zukunftsmusik die
nächsten Nächte jedenfalls bleiben kalt
nach Ostern allerdings sind wir den
Frost los wie sich am Trend für München
sehen können guten Abend